I've got good news everyone. Shikman is
going to be joining us live at 400 PM
Eastern time this Thursday. I sent him
the link to join. Now you may be
thinking to yourself, "Wait a minute,
isn't that the guy with like 50
different nicknames for all the messed
up stuff he's been exposed for doing?"
Yes, Shikman has a lot of nicknames. The
first was Shake Iban Fibbon. He earned
that nickname after he was repeatedly
caught lying. Then after he tried to
trick God logic by pretending that an
Arabic footnote with a typo was an
authentic hadith even though he
supposedly has a degree in hadith
studies. People started calling him Shik
Iben footnote. After that he sprayed
fake blood on himself and claimed that
he was the victim of an Islamophobic
hate crime. So people started calling
him Shake Iben Ketchup and Shake Ibben
Smlette. He told his followers that he
filed a police report and that the man
who attacked him was arrested, that he
pleaded guilty, and that he's
incarcerated.
Sadly for Dawa fans, police and the
courts confirmed that they have no
record of any of this being real. His
fans still believe it, though. Then
things took a darker turn as one of his
Daab buddies exposed him for committing
adultery. The poor guy sent his wife to
Shikman for marital counseling and
Shikman gave her some marital counseling
in bed and she stayed with Shikman
because he's a da upgrade. That earned
Shikman the new nickname Shik Ibanza for
the adultery.
A little later, one of Shikathman's
other wives filed a restraining order
for choking her during sex and for
beating her and for putting a gun to her
head and threatening to kill her. I
guess we can call him shake iben choken.
And then there's this from his former
dao buddy.
>> Sam. Sam Shimone, where are you? We put
a debate challenge out.
>> Osman. Osman, why you running from me?
Why you running from your Muslim
brother? Cuz you know that you're not a
real Muslim. All what you can do is go
after Sam Shimon for what? To make more
money. I invite you to an open debate in
public. If you're real Muslim, you can
debate me. We're going to question your
faith into Islam and how you practice
Islam. Do you know how to read the Holy
Quran? Do you have a master degree in
Hadith? Do you sleep with women who are
married? Did you analy your stepfather
in Mexico? Did you fake the stabbing?
Did they kick you out of the mosque? Do
you wear luxury clothes? Do you have two
Teslas? Are you being humble? Did you
beat your wife? Were you forced to move
out of San Diego?
As if all this weren't bad enough,
another DAWA pal exposed the whole group
for, in his words, smashing hoes on DA
trips, doing three-ways on DA trips,
running trains on girls during DA trips,
and so on.
>> Chat, you want to see who Warner really
is? I'm the wrong one. Warner, I'll
bring all the receipts and evidence.
Chat, this guy gets high as hell all day
and all night. Well, wahi, may Allah
curse me. This guy goes high to the
mosque. This guy literally goes to give
da high every day, chat. I've been
holding my tongue for months and and
like even years on these guys, bro.
These guys, bro, are pothe heads, weed
heads, doing everything, bro. Warner
said I'm in the mosque three times a
day, but you're but you're high. Let me
let me tell you guys something that all
they want to do is hide behind the
shield of Islam. This guy, bro, has been
milking the whole thing from the start.
Warner's been married nine times. Nine.
Nine times, chat. Muta. This guy's a
mut. This guy went on vacation with a
Moroccan girl, married her for 5
minutes, and then to and then divorced
her on the way home. And by by the way,
you think like he got married nine
times? Like, that's enough, brother.
This guy's smashing girls every weekend.
Malik, I just smashed this chick. I'm
like, bro, why you even doing that?
Warner called me while he was in Miami
and he had a chick. He was on FaceTime.
He had a chick in his bed.
This guy had a chick in his bed calling
me on FaceTime. A random girl that he
picked up. Hey chat, who knows about
Warner and Adam Salai having threesomes?
You want me to start name dropping your
whole life? You and Adam? You telling me
about you and Adam doing threesomes
together on DA trips? Adam's wife
dropped him and and and it was all
because Adam was having threesomes in
Chicago. Adam was having threesomes in
Chicago and Warner was sitting there
watching. Bro, Adam and all them, bro,
all fake at the club with with with heis
and then going to debate Logic and
getting baked and then the man comes
like, "Well, he meet us in Time Square,
bro. Why are we not in Time Square when
he was there? Logic can't Logic cannot
show up over here and let us know what
it is. Y'all don't even y'all listen,
I'm gonna be honest. These guys, bro,
all all of them fake. All of them. And
you think Sneo's any better? Adam and
Slim and Sneo all run trains and rooms
together with Warner there. But by the
way, chat, you know that these guys,
they lie. They say, "Oh, we don't like
Myin. We don't like Myin." But they went
to Colombia with Myron. Chat, what were
they doing in Colombia? What did him and
Sneo do in Colombia? And Myin, guys,
these guys were smashing birds in
Colombia, bro. Wahi. May Allah curse me
if I'm lying. I got I got the receipt
right here. He told me he was in
Colombia with Myron FaceTiming me. I saw
him on FaceTime with Myron what they
were doing. How they had girls with
bikinis in their house and they were
licking on their you know what in front
of people and taking videos.
>> All of them are bad.
>> Yeah, all of them.
>> Drop name. All of them. Especially this
this fat boy too on the screen.
>> You could say Warner, but I mean like
Muslim Lantern's bad.
>> Yeah, Muslim lanterns with him doing it
too. I bro I
>> You think he knows any of the stuff he's
doing,
>> brother? I have receipts of him and
Muslim Lantern and Sneo in Bosnia
[__] What are you on about?
>> Okay, that's crazy,
>> bro. They were [__] hoes. Yes, in
Bosnia.
>> Yes, they were.
>> All of them.
>> That's out of his mouth. He said they
all did it.
>> Malik didn't directly implicate Shikman,
even though Shikman is part of the same
group, but he made it clear that if
Shikman says something about him, he's
got plenty of info on Shik Uman.
More recently, Shikutman pulled one of
the dumbest stunts ever, although it
works for his fans who are all the
product of 40 generations of first
cousin marriage. Shikman challenged all
of us to debate and we all accepted, but
he turned all of us down.
Then he went live with a bunch of other
Muslims and asked why we're running from
him. Everything is a show for low IQ
Dawa fans with Shikutman.
But we're finally going to settle this.
Shikman is going to join us this
Thursday at 400 p.m. Eastern time. We're
going to discuss the Islamic dilemma.
And maybe Shikman will do a better job
than the other DA Bros were able to do
last year. He certainly won't be able to
do worse than they did, but we'll see
what happens. See you all on Thursday.
And welcome to 2026.
You just fine on me. You
just back on me. This [music] is a
powerful religion. There's a reason to
it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.